wer weiß schon von morgen sind
jeden tag das sind
wer
heute morgen sind immer und wieder aufs
neue beginnt
so sommer in der stadt wir sind hier im
wunderschönen münchen an der isar wollen
heute mal grillen
aber hier sind wir einfach zu viele
leute aber ich habe da so ein kleiner
geheimtipp
es ist ein toller platz fuhr ist noch
weiter nicht hier
die sonne geht bald unter freunde und
ich hab hunger und durst okay das wasser
scheint sehr kalt zu sein
ich würde sagen als erstes tun wir unser
bier in den fluss oder
darf nur nicht davonziehen zu des spiels
kaltgestellt kann losgehen
wir haben ja so ein picknick will muss
ich alles mitschleppen das alles dabei
wir haben nur eine chance ein
streichholz das muss jetzt funktionieren
denn jetzt schlägt's wetter und von hat
es noch 40 grad gehabt also tobi pass
auf ich sag dir mal was wir alles unter
bei haben wir haben auf jeden fall hier
eine ganze menge fleisch nichts für mich
für dich haben wir extra hier noch
vegetarisches grillfleisch gekauft das
ist sehr sehr lecker
bei einem echten grillfest dürfen
natürlich die büste nicht fehlen noch
kartoffelsalat und in münchen auch ganz
wichtig einen obersten flecker
streichkäse auf brot zu schmieren habe
überholt
hier
herrlich auf geht's heute wir noch 15
minuten bis das gewitter da es losgeht
turbo grill
die erste vollständig recht zu kunde das
ist jetzt der neueste trend dass man mit
dem schlauchboot die sehr unterstützt
trotzdem so eine kühlbox dabei genau
richtig jetzt also in der stadt darf man
nicht an der isar grillen weil da
beschweren sich die anwohner
deswegen muss man hier so 15 minuten im
fahrrad raus aber ich würde schon
es sieht stürmisch aus jede sekunde
so ist bei uns in folge keine münchen
schnell vorbei das ist der vorteil wenn
man drin ist